it's not an easy decision for the
organization
we all loved demar derozan the Toronto
Raptors select Tamar to Rosen
Thunder xlab
[Applause]
it's always been Toronto since I've been
here
you know my whole goal was to make this
whole country be known so many things
when I just drive through the city that
wasn't here that grew I'm far from done
think I haven't accomplished what I want
to accomplish it I am Toronto I
represent just a harder name buddy
you know I got so many girls that I
wanted copper steel and I just can't
wait to put that Jersey back on and keep
going
your seat look man myself growing no
looking at money my family growth that's
what it all start look like folks
tomorrow
no money back for five more years damar
has done so much for us
the Raptors traded four-time NBA
all-star demar derozan
to San Antonio damad is shocked and
saddened by this also he wanted to be in
Toronto he wanted to retire in Dorado he
loved it this is a business and it's
unfortunate but Lamar took it more
personal that put my blood sweat and
tears in this organization in now wasn't
done yet
what's the best thing about living in
Toronto every wealthy life here is great
the ckle his young to old is being
grazed
[Applause]
especially with girls come
you know how great the city is that
atmosphere that we get every single
night
the team here in Toronto
he's back